Good morning John.
Last week, I went to my first ever San Diego Comic Con.
I was there to do some panels, by myself and with some friends,
and also do a little performance.
I had a lot of thoughts in this place,
about how weird it is that I get to be on the same stage as people I consider super legitimately famous.
about how we create tiers of humanity and place extra weight on being part of one tier when
in fact I can solidly confirm that it is pretty identical to all the other tiers. About how conventions like this
and the ones that I help run serve to concentrate the reality of fandom and excitement and expression
into the real world and how great that is. But while at comic-con, I had a more abstract thought that hit me
pretty hard: there is so much media now! Oh my god, how do we consume it all?
When I got back home from comic-con, all my friends we talking about Stranger Things,
and I was like, "but, guy- I'm still catching up on Mr. Robot, I haven't even seen the new ghostbusters movie
yet. There's so much music, so many books, so many comics, so many shows and movies and podcasts
and youtube videos. And we are all constantly bombarded by voices telling us to eat these things up
real quick and as soon as you're done, move on to the next one. The media industry advestises on its own
media to push yet more media, whether that's reality TV, sitcoms, dramas, or the news. Never before has there
been anything like this much media. But John, I've got a secret for you. The special thing about comic-con isn't
the amount of media these people consume, it's the passion they have for it. And in a world where you
nibble and snack and then move on to the next thing, that passion, which is the source of so much joy in my
life, doesn't get developed. And so I asked myself, what are the shows, the books, the podcasts, the online
communities that I spend more time thinking about and contributing to than consuming? What are the pieces of
media that I go to over and over again, the albums that I can't stop listening to? The worlds I read fanfic in
because I don't want to stop being inside of them? The books I can read for a fourth time and still learn new
things about? The aren't that many. But I want there to be more. John, outside of my hotel room at comic-con,
there was a port for Dole produce. All of the shipping containers came off a boat, and then they got stored
and driven out by semi-trucks. And since this is a thoughts from places video, you might think I'm about
to make some weird, abstract connection between the stuff I was just talking about and this Dole shipping port
but that's just too much of a stretch, it's just that I wanted to show you this really cool timelapse
that I made. Anyway, I wanna snack less. And have more good, solid content meals. I wanna stop consuming
cheeto media and focus on the things in this world that make me love them. That take up my brain and make me
think for weeks afterward, that make me love the world and appreciate myself. I wanna love things the way that
these people love things. John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Hey. If you wanna love things like that too, I might suggest that you check out nerdcon stories, which is
an amazing opportunity to love great stuff. I might be a little bit biased because it is a conference that I literally
built with a team of really great people, but last year it was just a fantastic time and I'm very sad to say that
I won't be able to attend this year for reasons that will become clear, especially if you listen to next week's Dear
Hank and John, or if you check out a very long video  that I just uploaded on hankschannel.
So I won't be there, but John will, and so will a bunch of other amazing people like John Scalzi, Mary Robinette
Kowal, Dylan Marron, Ben Acker and Ben Blacker, Cindy Pon, M. T. Anderson, John Darnielle of The Mountain
Goats, Dessa Darling, Maureen Johnson, Nalo Hopkinson, Patrick Rothfuss, Paolo Bacigalupi,
a ton of other great people, it's gonna be a wonderful time. I'm really sad that I can't be there but I hope that
you all have a great time without me. If you want to find out more, you can go to nerdcon.com.